(Crowd cheering)
(Upbeat music playing)
Hey guys. Welcome to, Game of love.
And I'm your host, Leesie.
Today, I'm accompanied,
by two handsome bachelors,
Brian and Lucas.
Do you guys wanna introduce yourselves?
- Sure. I'm Brian.
I'm 23. I'm from Torrance, California.
I'm an actor, director, creator.
And for fun, I like to play basketball.
I box. And, I love to take photos.
- I'm Lucas. I'm from
Redondo beach, California.
I am also, an actor.
I'm also, an aspiring firefighter.
And, I like camping.
I like biking and I like building stuff.
- Hey, He'll come in handy.
Today's game, is tug of war.
Suitors, when it's your turn,
line up behind the bachelor,
you'd like to date.
(whistle blowing)
(Upbeat music playing)
These are your teams.
You have five minutes,
to speed date, each side.
Starting, Now.
(Whistle blowing)
- Let's get the Kindergarten
questions, out of the way.
Favorite food?
- French fries.
- Mac and cheese
- Japanese ramen.
- I love fries too,
but I could love a good
Poke bowl, as well.
- Sushi.
- Oh, same, Sushi.
- Mine is, Mole.
It's a Mexican dish.
- Dave's hot chicken.
- I like fluff, which is like,
a Vietnamese noodle soup.
- Okay, all good answers.
I'm not a raw fish, person.
So, I can't do sushi.
Who or what, is your style inspiration.
- Anything really, Avant-garde
- I could be caught in sweatpants
or just like, in a Whole fit.
- I really like, like Parisian fashion,
like elegant, classy.
- Modern glam.
Like something that, really
accentuates my long legs.
- Taylor the creator.
It's like my,
I literally look up to him,
with style and all that stuff.
- Truly. Who doesn't.
- I would say like edgy,
but like, build it up,
to make it like, more fancy.
I like to play around.
I thrift a lot
- Cool. Thrifting is awesome.
Save the planet.
- Yeah.
(Lucas laughing)
- In terms of, the amount
of confidence she has,
when she wears anything,
I really just wanna pad the
same energy, as Dolly Parton.
- I love that answer.
- Style inspos.
Definitely My mom. 'Cause
her style fucking rocks.
So, yeah.
(whistle blowing)
- That is the end, of
the speed dating, round.
Lucas. Do you have a side, You prefer?
- Ah, I think I'm going
to go, with the red team.
- Would you like to add
a player from the bench?
- No. Let's do, evens.
- Suitors.
There is a flag, in the middle of the rope
and two lines on either side.
Whichever line it crosses first,
is the winning team.
On my whistle, begin.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheering)
Blue team.
You guys are eliminated.
And that's the team you wanted.
So you are now stuck, with the blue team.
- And all are strong
- Not Stuck.
- All right. Welcome to
the speed dating, round.
Brian.
You get to speed date,
these lovely ladies, for 10 minutes.
On my whistle, go.
(Whistle blows)
- What are you guys' red flags, on a guy.
Starting from you.
- One of the things that,
I usually look out for, is empathy.
- Gotcha. Gotcha.
- A persistent liar.
(Selah laughs)
- How they treat people, around them.
So if we're going to a restaurant
and they're rude to a waiter,
then he's gonna have, the
same treatment towards me.
- Negativity. 'Cause what's
from the inside, comes outside.
- Prefer when they have a bed frame.
(everyone laughs)
That's probably, the biggest one.
- What's your idea for like, a first date?
- I really enjoy, going
on picnics at parks
and sometimes painting.
and doing photography.
and yeah.
- Sometimes there's
like, a pressure of like,
who's paying for who?
On like, if you go to
like, a fancy dinner.
So I'd rather like, maybe
like, cook at home together.
Eat like, a light meal.
- I love going out to dinner.
If we end up vibing, I
guess you should say,
going out to the bars, after.
If not, that's your scapegoat.
Dinner's over and you
can run out of there.
- Cool.
- Going out to one of
our favorite restaurants.
Through that way,
I can either try out, what
you like or what I like.
So, you might try something new.
- Definitely going to
the restaurant, first.
But if it goes well,
then just walking around
and looking at stuff.
- Cool.
(People laughing)
(Whistle blows)
- Brian, do you know
what side, you prefer?
- I'm gonna say, blue team.
- Blue team.
Do you wanna add someone,
to the side that you prefer?
- Yeah. I'll take the
girl, on the far right.
(crowd cheering)
- On my whistle.
Tug of war.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
Blue team.
(whistle blows)
Blue team wins.
Congratulations, Blue team.
Red team.
Unfortunately, you have
no shot with Brian.
You did good though.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Boom.
The same rules apply.
But this time,
you have five minutes,
to speed date each side.
And then at the end, if you prefer a side,
you can always add someone from the bench.
But you don't have to.
(Whistle blows)
- All right. Let's get
into nitty gritty stuff.
Like a red flag.
And then, the opposite of a red flag.
A green flag, whatever you call it.
- Red flag. They're selfish
or they don't have a job.
A green flag would be somebody,
who is very like, outward driven.
So they're selfless people.
- Something I really
like, is open mindedness.
'Cause I feel I get along,
with a lot of, different type of people.
On the opposite side, close mindedness.
- Someone that values money too much.
And a green flag would be,
someone that knows how to
communicate their feelings.
- I say a red flag,
if you don't know how to take,
a piece of the humble pie.
Like sometimes it's like,
we are in a heated argument.
Like we need, to all just sit down
and if you are just aggressive about it,
I just, it gets to a bad place.
A green flag, totally, would just be like,
if you're spontaneous and you're social,
I would vibe off somebody,
that's like that.
- A red flag is, somebody
who's always on their own time.
A green flag is, somebody
who wants somebody,
to just, be friends with
and also like, be romantic with.
- Do you guys have
ex-boyfriends, ex-girlfriends
- Yes sir.
- So, what ended the relationship?
- My ex-boyfriend, he'll
probably be watching this.
I don't care.
I broke up with him.
He was a very conceited
and arrogant person.
- The last person I was seeing,
is kind of, two different personalities,
looking for different things.
Yeah. Didn't work out.
- Cool.
- No one's been lucky enough, to be my ex.
(Lucas laughs)
- Yeah. I love that. That's awesome.
- Perfect.
- Me and my ex,
we completely moved, to
different sides of the country.
That will just, never work.
- Oh, it was the distance.
You didn't move, 'cause
you hated each other?
- No, it was, it was not, it
was literally the distance
and probably just, we'll never align.
So I'm just like, just do your thing.
I'll do my thing.
- I was with somebody, for on
and off, for like two years.
I think we both like, did
not trust each other enough,
to kind of, even go there.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
- Do you have a side, you prefer?
- No. Yes.
Then, I guess I'll go with, the blue side.
- And would you like to pull someone,
from the bench, to help the blue side?
- I will write my wrongs and
add someone to the blue side.
- All right.
Who would you like to pick?
- I don't think I got names.
So Yeezys. Go.
- Me?
- Yeah, you. Get up here.
(Crowd cheers)
(Whistle blows)
(whistle blows)
- Blue team, wins.
Red team.
I'm so sorry, but you don't get to date.
All right. Same rules apply.
You have five minutes now,
to speed date, these lovely ladies.
- Cool.
- I'll be back.
(whistle blows)
- Are you guys, family oriented?
- Yes, pretty much just me
and my immediate family.
Since I'm living across the
country, from them right now.
It's kind of hard, but I see
them, probably once a month.
- Family first, always.
I live, for family's happiness.
- I'm very close to my family.
My immediate family, is the
only one in California, so.
- Oh wow. Okay.
- Yeah. We just stick together
- For sure. Are you guys
friends with your ex?
- No.
- Okay.
- Are you friends with your ex?
(Suitors laugh)
- No.
- Would you try to be
friends, with your ex?
- I would try to be on good terms.
(whistle blows)
- Brian, do you have a side, you prefer?
- I do have a side,
that I want to help out.
Let's get you, helping out red.
- Yeah, that's good.
(crowd claps)
- I got you.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- Same rules apply.
On my whistle.
Tug of war.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
Red team.
Red team. Congratulations.
You are now a finalist.
And now, you guys are gonna, tug of war,
to see who, the next finalist is.
You guys are competing,
for Brian's final slot.
I know you guys, just became besties
and I'm sorry to do this.
But on my whistle, Tug of war.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
You're now the finalist.
Good job. Good job.
You have five minutes,
to speed date each side.
And if you prefer a side, at the end,
you can always choose someone,
from the bench, to help them out.
(whistle blows)
- Let's go back to Ex's.
All right.
I know you haven't had an Ex,
so we'll make an exception.
Are you friends with your Ex?
And if you are, why?
If you aren't, why not?
- So I have two Ex's.
But my most recent ex, blocked.
Would never talk to him again.
- One guy I was seeing,
sometimes we'll talk.
So we're friendly.
And then the other guy,
I just don't really talk to, anymore.
- I feel like, I'd definitely
try to be friends with them,
unless it was toxic then probably not.
- So what's like, toxic?
- Uh. That's a good one.
- Like if they make me question my values.
I feel like, that's toxic to Me.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
- I'm gonna add someone from
the bench, to the red team
and just, see what happens.
Who's yoked?
- Molly
(crowd cheers)
- Molly, Molly
- Molly, Molly.
(whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
Red team wins.
- All right.
Congratulations. You are a finalist.
- I almost take (indistinct)
- You guys will compete,
against each other,
to see who the next finalist will be.
All right. On my whistle.
You guys will be competing,
for Lucas' final spot.
Are you guys ready?
(Whistle blows)
(crowd cheers)
- Where did it, even end?
- Wait, I'm confused.
We might need to watch a playback.
'Cause I think, it crossed here.
- Okay. Let's watch playback, real quick.
(upbeat music playing)
- Okay. Okay.
We got it.
- And the winner, of
the tug of war contest,
Is
Drum rolls Please.
(crowd slaps knees)
Boom.
(crowd cheers)
- All right, Lucas.
This is the final round.
Do you know, who you're picking?
- Yeah, sure.
- Are you confident in that answer?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay. You need to be confident,
because I'm giving you
a shared cash prize,
that can use on your first date.
Whenever you're ready.
- Right On. You guys are
both, like seriously,
such amazing people.
Like, I've only known
you guys, for how long?
but I think, I'm going to go with,
Edie, on this one.
- Yay.
(crowd cheers)
- Congratulations Edie.
Are you Okay? Come here.
- Brian. This is the final round.
Do you know, who you're picking?
- I think so.
- Are you sure?
- Yeah
- Because I'm about, to give
you a shared cash prize,
that you're gonna use, on your first date.
So be positive.
- Sure.
- Hit it ladies.
(crowd slaps knees)
- Let's see.
I'm gonna have to pick,
Hannah.
(crowd cheers)
- Good job, Ruby.
Lets go to the bench.
(crowd cheers)
- Oh my God.
Where did it, even end?